did you just say that you think in terms
of likelihood life started on MAR like
uh statistically speaking well I started
on Mars and seated Earth it could be
possible because life was like saying
Mars was habitable uh for the type of
life that we have right now type of
chemistry before Earth so it seems to me
that Mars got searching doing chemistry
okay and started way before yeah and so
they had a few more replicators and some
other stuff and if those replicators got
ejected from Mars and landed on Earth an
Earth would like I don't need to start
again right thanks for that and then it
just carries on so I I'm not going I
think there is we will find evidence of
Life on Mars either life we put there by
mistake contamination or actually life
the earliest remnants of life
um and that would be really exciting
it's a really good reason to go there
but I think it's more unlikely because
the gravitational situation in the solar
system if we find life in the outside
system Titan and all that that'll be its
own thing exactly wow that would be so
cool if I would go to Mars and we find
life that looks a hell of a lot similar
to Earth life and then we'll go to uh
Titan and all those weird moons with the
ices and the volcanoes and all that kind
of stuff and then we find there
something that looks I don't know way
weirder yeah some other some non-rna
type of oh in my situation almost life
like in the Prebiotic chemical space and
I think there are four types of
exoplanets we can go look for right
because when jwst goes up and touch wood
it goes up and everything's fine when we
look at a star well we know
statistically most stars have planets
around them what type of Planet are they
are they going to be dead are they going
to be just a Prebiotic origin of Life
coming so are they going to be
technological
and you know so we have Intelligence on
them and will they will they have died
so what so you know from you know had
life on them because all the four states
before and so and suddenly it's a bit
like I want to classify planets the way
we classify Stars yeah and I think that
in terms of their rather than having
this all we've found out we've found
methane there's evidence of life we
found oxygen that's the evidence of life
we found whatever molecule marker
um and start to then frame things a
little bit more because those four
states yeah which by the way you're just
saying four but there could be a
um before the dead there could be other
states that we humans can even
conceiving yeah just Prebiotic almost
alive you know got the possibility to
come alive I think um but there could be
a post-technological like whatever we
think of as technology there could be uh
uh uh like pre-conscious
like where we all meld into one super
intelligent conscious or some weird
thing that naturally happens over tell
you